digamos que estamos observando un objeto
que está dando vueltas en el espacio
viajando en una ruta circular vamos a
dibujar aquí más o menos cada uno de los
vectores velocidad durante el recorrido
de este objeto que están dando vueltas
entonces quiero hacer énfasis aunque el
dibujo no sea muy preciso que las
magnitudes de todos estos vectores son
las mismas no cambian
lo que está cambiando es la dirección de
esta de esta ruta
lo que quiero hacer es reflexionar sobre
qué es lo que se necesita aunque el tipo
de fuerza tiene que intervenir para que
cambie la dirección de vector velocidad
recordemos que si no tuviéramos una
fuerza actuando según la primera ley del
movimiento de newton la velocidad no
cambiaría ni en su magnitud ni en su
dirección si no hubiera una fuerza
actuando sobre este objeto continuaría
moviéndose en la misma dirección no
girar ya así que vamos a pensar cuál
sería la dirección de dicha fuerza y voy
a dibujar estos vectores para saber cuál
es el cambio en la dirección entre uno y
otro
voy a tratar de dibujarlos
lo más parecido más o menos esté aquí
ahora lo que van a tener ambos estos
vectores es
que van a estar
con el mismo origen recuerden que siendo
vectores podemos cambiar o ponerlos en
cualquier lugar siempre conserva en la
dirección
y la posición
no me quedaron muy bien siempre que
conserven la dirección y la posición
va a ser el mismo vector así que no
importa si los agrupó todos juntos más o
menos ahí está bueno está muy prolijo el
dibujo pero digamos que así vamos a
tener que trabajar entonces analicemos
este vector con el siguiente el cambio
en la dirección no nos va a dar este
vector
este
entonces digamos que desde el punto de
vista del objeto que estamos viendo este
es el primer cambio de la dirección del
vector velocidad entonces es cambio está
este triangulito significa delta y
significa cambio de velocidad
si yo dibujara este vector en este
círculo este vector que va a dibujar
sería más o menos
el cambio de dirección iría por acá más
o menos
del tav el delta de ahora si yo reviso
el cambio de dirección entre este vector
y este otro será algo similar aunque
bueno aquí las magnitudes de mis cambios
están un poco buenas más tanto a la
escala o en la proporción que debería
ser y este es otro cambio
en la dirección de la velocidad si lo
graficó aquí
será más o menos así
y también de aquí acá si hago la
diferencia en velocidad
sería acá
si lo dibujo más o menos va a ser algo
así
y ahora bueno ya vemos los cambios de
dirección esta sería la fuerza o lo que
nos ocasiona que este vector velocidad
cambie su dirección sí cual tengamos
redibujó dibujando estos cambios de
velocidad que veríamos qué patrón se
está notando aquí
bueno pues pareciera de entrada que al
menos todos estos elementos estos
cambios en la velocidad son
perpendiculares al vector velocidad
original es decir tienen aquí un ángulo
de 90 grados con respecto a la velocidad
que traía
aquí se nota el ángulo también de 90
grados
y pareciera que todos estos vectores se
están dirigiendo hacia un lugar en
particular hacia un centro como si esto
fuera un círculo y aquí tuviéramos un
centro
y sabemos por la primera ley de newton
que si la velocidad está cambiando
aunque la magnitud sea la misma si si la
velocidad cambia ya sea en magnitud o
dirección o en ambas entonces existe una
fuerza neta que está actuando sobre el
objeto y esta fuerza neta que está
actuando en la dirección de la
aceleración es lo que está cocinando
este cambio de dirección
esta fuerza parecida que está jalando el
objeto a este centro
y por eso se llama esta fuerza fuerza
centrípeta no confundir con fuerza
centrífuga que es muy diferente entonces
es la fuerza
/ zeta
centrípeta
esto significa esta fuerza se entre esta
parte de la palabra centre pues bueno
significa el centro y peta
es algo así como buscar
busca entonces una fuerza que busca al
ir al centro o busca el centro entonces
lo podemos poner cómodo
fuerza
qué
/ e
comillas busca
busca
al centro porque toda esta fuerza se
está dirigiendo hacia un mismo punto
entonces por eso s entry peta así es que
nos vamos a acordar de esta palabra
curiosa el objetivo de hacer todo esto
fue que porque para mí no quedaba claro
el que si tenemos un objeto que se está
moviendo en un círculo el cambio de
velocidad o la aceleración actual de
nuestro objeto tenía que estar centrada
o tener un centro o dirigirse a un
centro es por eso que dibuje estos
vectores y los puse de este de esta
forma o de este tornado graficando su
diferencia para mostrar que el cambio en
la velocidad se dirige al centro una vez
aclarado esto ustedes se pueden
preguntar en donde ocurre esto en la
vida real bueno uno de los ejemplos más
típicos y que creo yo al menos todos
hemos usado de niños es el yoyo
si imaginas si ustedes tienen
un yoyo
más o menos así
y lo amarran
o lo atan con una cuerda
y se ponen a girar con su mano tienen
agarrada esta cuerda y se ponen a darle
vueltas al yo yo pues bueno que va a
ocurrir o qué es lo que han visto qué
ocurre pues en el yoyo se pone a girar
en círculos va a estar dando vueltas
la magnitud de la velocidad puede ser
constante pero la dirección de la
velocidad va a estar cambiando
constantemente yendo en círculo y esto
lo ocasiona la mano de ustedes que
sostiene este
el cordón que está jalando el yoyo hacia
el centro otro ejemplo es cuando tenemos
y objetos en órbita de la tierra por
ejemplo
imaginamos que esta es la superficie
de la tierra y por acá tenemos un
satélite de comunicaciones
entonces este objeto va a estar dando
vueltas
a la tierra pero aunque su velocidad va
a mantenerse constante
la dirección va a cambiar va a mantener
una línea bueno no una línea va a ser
una curva una órbita va a estar en
órbita pero va a haber una fuerza que
está actuando sobre este objeto y está
evitando que se salga o se vaya lejos de
la tierra esto es el tirón gravitatorio
que va a jalar esto o intentar mantener
esto dirigido hacia el centro de la
tierra
y tenemos otro ejemplo aún más cotidiano
en el que la mayoría o muchos de
nosotros hemos tenido la experiencia de
viajar en auto entonces imaginen
este es un
un auto visto desde arriba
medio extraño pero aquí están sus
llantas y imagínense que este auto está
dando vueltas o está o está digamos que
es un auto de carreras y está en una
pista de carreras y puede estar girando
alrededor de esta pista eso es algo muy
interesante ya que para muchos como las
acometidas comentaba este es una
experiencia muy común y podemos ver en
el edo metro o lo que mide la velocidad
en el auto que este auto puede ir a una
velocidad constante pero está viajando
en círculo no hay una cuerda que esté
jalando del vehículo hacia centro y no
existe una mágica gravedad que atraiga
este vehículo y lo haga moverse del lado
obviamente está la gravedad que lo
mantiene en el suelo pero no que lo esté
haciendo moverse del lado
qué es lo que causa entonces que este
auto pueda dar la vuelta en su lugar de
seguir derecho si no hubiera otra fuerza
bueno pueden detener el vídeo y pensar
en ello un momento y si no pues aquí les
voy a decir lo que ocasiona esto es de
hecho la fuerza de fricción entre la
sientes y el camino y una buena
demostración de que esto es cierto es
que si ustedes quitan la fricción en el
camino es y si tienen el auto sobre
aceite o sobre el hielo el auto no va a
dar la vuelta aunque ustedes giren las
llantas para que dé la vuelta el auto va
a seguir la dirección del movimiento